queen elizabeth chose a milestone event
to share an important message
there is a lot of talk of succession at
the moment this is the queen's platinum
jubilee year when she will celebrate in
june 70 years on the throne and
inevitably that's going to open up talk
about the future
as the monarch celebrated her 70th
jubilee she announced prince charles
wife camilla will become queen consort
when charles ascends the throne the
queen said quote it is my sincere wish
that when the time comes camilla will be
known as queen consort as she continues
her own loyal service
following the announcement a
spokesperson for the prince of wales
said charles and camilla are quote
touched and honored by her majesty's
words the role of consort is a
meaningful one for the queen she also
noted in her message quote i was blessed
that in prince philip i had a partner
willing to carry out the role of consort
and unselfishly make the sacrifices that
go with that today tomorrow
you know because it's 70 years strong
the queen's remarks came the same day as
a reception she hosted at sandringham
house members from local charities
attended the event where her majesty
chatted with guests and enjoyed gifts
including this mosaic made by school
children
i thought it had to be upside down for
the present practice
[Laughter]
and the queen even got some laughs while
cutting the cake i think i might just
put a knife in i think that's a really
good idea
see if it works oh yes
beautifully
somebody else can finish it off do the
rest of it
this event marked the queen's first in
person appearance in three months
following multiple health issues we know
that so much planning is going into the
jubilee celebrations in june and it's
been some time now well october since we
last saw the queen in person and i think
certainly people are are still concerned
about the queen's health we understand
that one very much wants to get back to
work but i think it's it's going to be a
case of making sure she really has made
a full and complete recovery before
courtyards start packing up a busy work
schedule
the official platinum jubilee
celebrations will be held in the uk in
june the 95 year old is the first
british royal to reach seven decades on
the throne my understanding is that the
moment really is just about carrying out
light dust work at windsor
more virtual audiences and meetings and
really making sure that the queen is
in
tip-top health um ahead of her june
jubilee celebrations which for the queen
and for the royal family are very much
the focal of 2022
[Music]
you